we're told that f of x is equal to two x
times the square root of five minus four
and we're also told that g of x is equal
to x squared plus two x times the square
root of five minus one and they want us
to find
g minus f
of x so pause this video and see if you
can work through that on your own
so the key here is to just realize what
this notation means g minus f of x is
the same thing as g
of x
minus
f of x
and so again if this was helpful to you
once again i encourage you to pause the
video
all right now let's work through this
again so this is going or i guess the
first time but now that we know that
this is equal to g of x minus f of x so
what is g of x well that's the same
thing as
x squared plus 2x times the square root
of 5 minus 1. and what is f of x
well it's going to be
2 x times the square root of 5 minus 4
and we are subtracting f x from g of x
so let's subtract this is f x from g of
x and so now it's just going to be a
little bit of algebraic simplification
so this is going to be equal to
this is equal to
x squared plus 2x times the square root
of 5
minus 1. and now we just have to
distribute this negative sign so
negative 1 times 2x times the square
root of 5 is we're going to have minus
2x times the square root of 5 and then
the negative of negative 4 is positive 4
and let's see if we can simplify this
sum so this is going to be equal to we
only have one x squared term so that's
that one there so we have x squared and
let's say we have 2x times the square
root of 5 and then we have another oh
now we subtract 2x times the square root
of 5. so these two cancel out each with
each other
so those cancel out and then we have
minus 1
plus 4. so if we have negative 1 and
then we add 4 to it we're going to have
positive 3. so if we just factor if we
take this and this into consideration
four minus one is going to be equal to
three and we're done that's what g minus
f of x is equal to x squared plus three